in the last weeks and months we
interviewed candidates for different
words in our company and it was just
insane to see and observe what some of
these people do and say in these
interviews in this video I'm covering
four tips for crucial mistakes which I
have observed other people to do quite
frequently in these kind of job
interviews and I'd like to discuss them
to help you avoid these mistakes when
you are interviewing for new wrote hi
guys my name is Heinrich welcome to
another coffee break with firm learning
I hope you're having a great day today I
was sitting again and still my home
office here in Munich in while I was
working on different tasks I was
reflecting a bit on the last weeks and
months because in our company and as
some of you know I left consulting about
half a year ago and now I joined a
retail company in Germany and I have a
CTO role in this company so in our
company in the last weeks and months we
interviewed different candidates for
several roads and not reflecting on that
it was just crazy right so why are we
had some amazing candidates that really
fit the roads where we had also some
candidates which did or said things
which I just cannot believe that these
people said that so reflected a bit on
that and I try to come up with a bit of
a condensate of that right so what were
the top four mistakes that these people
are doing in the interview and
apparently these people didn't realize
that these were things which probably
didn't come across very well because
otherwise the one I've done err and I
want to help you to avoid these mistakes
that you do not do these mistakes if
this is the first time that you're
watching my channel just let me briefly
introduce myself to you my name is
Heinrich and on this channel I try to
help you be successful in the first
years of your career so it doesn't
matter if you're fresh college graduate
or you're ready in the first years of
your career this channel is all about
tips and tricks what you can do to help
you become a professional and developers
have both from the private but also from
the world perspective so if you like any
of the content on this channel at all
please press the like button for the
YouTube algorithm it also subscribed to
much
no in order that you get all the new
videos I will release and of course also
please hit the notification there to
make sure you're not missing out
so for crucial mistakes that I have
observed these job candidates do let's
start with the first one so this is a
lack of commitment and investment from
the side of the candidate so what
exactly do I mean by that what I mean is
that if you talk to the candidate if you
interview them they're just some people
that you know you're just directly sense
that you're just one of many companies
on his list the property is interviewing
with three or four companies at the same
time and in the end he doesn't really
really care where exactly works there
are really hard reasons why he would
prefer your company over the other in
the end probably the only thing that
would matter to him is either the salary
or maybe some other benefits but he does
not really care for your company and
this especially becomes obvious when you
realize that he didn't do any basic
research at all about your company the
bare minimum that you need to prepare if
you interview for company is to at least
have some basic stats of the company in
your head right so what is roughly the
revenue that the company is making how
many employees do they have in what
geographies do they operate so this is
the bare minimum of research and
commitment that you need to show in
order for us as interviewers to make it
clear that you really want the job and
of course this is especially easy if the
work for publicly traded company because
for these companies there are and your
reports that you can just flip through
and you will easily get all these key
stats but even if it's not a publicly
traded company there are many other
sources of information that you can use
so of course on the one hand side you
could just look for the company website
are any infos on there but even if the
company doesn't have such website or
doesn't provide these kinds of
information on it in most countries
there are some type of commercial
registers where you can just pull these
kind of information in Germany there's
the hundreds register you can just look
into bundes on saigon de it's a publicly
available internet site
Germany then you just type in the name
of the company and the latest any
reports that are fired from this company
will be available there so even if it's
not a publicly traded company but an HD
on NSE or Germany of GmbH you will get
these kind of basic financial
information on the company and of course
this might give you also important
insights as a recruit so my perspective
it would seem very important if you look
into joining a company to understand
what the financial situation is in which
the company is in is it doing well is
not doing well if it's not doing really
well what are the reasons why is it not
doing well how or does this might affect
your position that you want to start in
so do this painting research and then
show your interviewer that you did this
research to the both sides some kind of
comfort now talking about some positive
examples what can you actually do in
order to really show some commitment and
investment into the company so what one
of the candidates for instance that that
we interviewed us he visited several of
our stores and he also made an order in
our online shop to get a feel of what
the experience is when buying with us
both online and offline and he was able
to in the interview give us quite a few
tangible feedback points when what his
experience are and what he would
potentially recommend to improve and as
he was also looking to work in a say
it's related role of course this made
perfect sense
this showed us that this guy is serious
I mean he already did some effort to
understand what he couldn't prove he
already showed us that he has the
stamina to really go there to some test
orders go Howard visit stores and this
already put in far ahead of some other
applicants who did not even research the
most basic information on our company so
do some research invest prior to coming
to the interview in terms of money or
time to show the people that through a
series that you really want the job and
are willing to go an extra mile to get
there and to provide an ad venue for the
company a second very big very big
mistake a second very big red flag big
mistake that many candidates do is to
not show any end
to not show any self-reflection in these
interviews so very frequently interviews
will consist of some kind of questions
of the type that they ask you what the
interviewer for maybe a difficult
problem you faced in your professional
life especially challenge that you had
in your professional life before just to
get a feel of what type of challenges
you were already confronted with in the
past and then also how you react to
these kind of situations and I get the
feeling that some candidates think that
they should avoid at all costs showing
any kind of weakness any kind of doubt
when answering these kind of questions
but this often leads to an answer that
sounds like this with the candidate
pretty much saying that there are these
very tough and serious issues that I was
facing and all these other people around
me they were clueless they had no idea
there were idiots right but I am then
the big hero and I walk in and I solved
everything and I came up with this great
solution right and the reason why these
kind of answers do not work or are not
good answers is because they do not show
that you have empathy they do not show
that you have self reflection that you
can put yourself into the shoes of your
colleagues of other partners and
understand what they are thinking what
their emotions are because the truth is
especially when facing tough and
challenging problems it's not black and
white some other people might behave
very contour and to ative to you it
might be very difficult for you to
understand why they are behaving in a
certain way but if you try to put
yourself in their shoes and try to
understand what they are feeling what
they are thinking
then this often enables you to
understand their perspective and then
also jointly collaborate on a solution
to a certain problem and these kind of
team oriented problem-solving skills are
highly important and a lot of modern
work environments and the reason why
this is so important is that today
leaders need to have empathy it is
really difficult to build followers in
an organization to build a tribe of
people that really supports you
you do not have empathy if you are not
able as you know to also help them
encourage them and able them and all of
this requires empathy and
self-reflection and make sure that in
your answer Susie's kind of challenge
oriented or problem oriented questions
you show that you have this empathy this
is just so important third big mistake
that many people are doing is
bad-mouthing the road employer and I get
it it's okay right there is often a
reason why you would left your job maybe
you quit the position or maybe your
employer could you and often this can
leave you with some bad feelings and of
course if asked it's completely fine to
maybe also mention a few points while
you've just liked your prior role and
what motivated you know to make the
transition this is of course absolutely
fine
no problem about that but then we had
some candidates and not only one but
several of them when just on and on and
on just talking bad about their prior
situation how all of their colleagues
all of these other people just didn't
get it making it sound like they were
pretty much the only intelligent person
in the room describing all kinds of
problems at the prior employer now they
were the ones who realize that but
apparently everybody else around them
did not realize it and this type of
behavior is bad for two reasons first it
just makes you look like a very negative
person if I'm looking for colleagues to
work with I do not want to have a
colleague who is just complaining about
everybody and everything all day long I
want some positivity around me and of
course it's okay to also make some
critical remarks but this always needs
to be in a context and not just out of a
habit of complaining all the time so
this is the first reason but the second
reason comes back to another video that
I did it's called the video problem
solver problem talker and I will
included buf me that you can check it
out if you haven't seen it yet but it
describes how a person can either be a
problem talker or a problem solver and I
don't want to go into all the details
right now but if you're a person just
complain so makes it looks like you got
it all right you understood
all these other people around you didn't
this very much makes you look like a
problem talker and for reasons I
explained in this other video what
companies need and want our problem
solvers because the truth is the like
note is pretty high but all the problems
that you are describing about your old
employer there's a high chance that you
would have had some opportunity to do
something about them right so all these
things were going wrong what was your
contribution in your company to fix it
to make it better and again the truth is
usually much more complex then you pick
the intelligent star understood at all
and wanted to do your best but you just
couldn't show that you solve these
problems to try to pass to really and
then you'll make an impact and don't
just explain all day long about what
other peoples were doing wrong and my
last mistake is regarding body language
and perceived energy level it is just
important to understand that how you are
perceived as a candidate is of course
driven on the one hand side by what you
say but also on the other side how would
you say it what your body language is
when you say it and just let me try to
imitate it there were job candidates who
were just making themselves small were
sitting like this in their chairs and
some of them has had some really
intelligent things but if you just say
it by talking in a very monotone as'
voice by talking with a very quiet voice
if you just make yourself small like
this this is just not how you are
perceived where it might be alright what
you say it might make total sense but
you seem like a person who cannot
articulate yourself where who probably
has a problem with being perceived with
some kind of authority in front of other
people
would probably have a hard time
persuading other colleagues which is of
course an important business skill and
also they're perceived with a lower
energy level and of course this always
comes down to personality as well there
some people just naturally have
higher energy level than others and this
is completely fine but what you usually
do not want as an employer to have
somebody on an extreme just sits there
makes themself small and just radiates a
very low energy never what you actually
want as an employer is somebody who just
works there with lots of energy somebody
who looks like he can take her ten new
problems every day and can just move
mountains right and of course not
exaggerating a bit but this is what
you're looking out for as an employer so
at least try to make your best
impression in de job interview and even
if you are a bit of an introvert this is
completely okay of course so no problem
with that but try to at least show some
personality in the interview so that you
have some energy in you that you can
move things that you are a mover and
shaker so that you have your potential
future employer see this kind of energy
in you and see this ability of your
story taking things go in there and also
go into a find if required so these were
the four mistakes let me just reiterate
and repeat so the first is not showing
any kind of commitment and investment
not showing some kind of research that
you did what you need to do is show that
you research the company that you know
the details that you maybe went the
extra mile maybe called the hotline and
the b2b company looked into a sense they
want to understand the product maybe do
the test order whatever the product is
of your company show that you did an
investment that you really want to work
for the company and add some value for
the company second especially for
leadership roles show that you have
empathy and the ability to save reflect
portray yourself as the leader who tries
to make an effort to understand what
other people think and feel because if
you cannot do that you were struggling
and this is something that many
employers will look out for search don't
express too much negativity don't go on
and on criticizing your own employer
just talking how bad everything was and
how other people just didn't get it
show some positivity people do not want
to be surrounded by negativity all day
long so don't be proceeded
if there's a negative person and last
but not least look out for your body
language your perceived energy level
show that you have the energy to take
your difficult tasks and don't make
yourself smaller than you are and don't
talk with a quiet monotonously
because this usually will not help you
so what I can just tell you now having
interviewed several candidates in the
last weeks and months if you will do all
these things in your next job interview
I can promise you that you are a
significant step ahead of many many
other job candidates out there so I hope
this makes sense to you let me know what
you think in the comments what are your
tips and tricks for job interviews what
were situations that you were confronted
with in your past you have a question
about a difficult situation that you
maybe had in the past and you would like
to have my perspective on that let me
know in the comments and I try to give
you an answer and if you took any value
out of this video at all please press
the like button for the YouTube
algorithm to help other people discover
this video as well and please subscribe
to my channel also hit the notification
there to see more videos like that and
as some of you already know I also have
a course on how to create PowerPoint
presentations a top consulting firms to
check out the link into the description
to this course they're already over
10,000 students who take it in the link
you will see lots of review so have a
look for yourself whether this is
something that might be of interest to
you thank you very much for watching I
will release at least one video every
week on Saturdays on this channel so
stay tuned thanks again for watching
I'm Heinrich from firm learning and have
a good day